Speaker 1: One of the things we've been talking
about for some time is that the Republican Party
has completely given up on policy. They just
they don't even talk about policy anymore.
Sometimes it sort of sounds like maybe they're
approximating what might be considered policy,
but it's essentially just cultural issues.
But I have for you today a supposed policy
platform. This is from Republican Senator
Rick Scott, who published an 11 point plan
to quote Rescue America. It's delusional, depraved
and disgusting and dangerous, and we're going to
take a look at what is on this plan. And he will
very quickly see that for the most part, this is
just cultural nonsense masquerading as policy.
We won't spend a ton of time on each point, but
I'll give you a sense of what they are. Point one
our kids will say the Pledge of Allegiance Salute
the flag learned that America is a great country
and choose the school that best fits them. That
all together is an attack on funding of public
schools in favor of charter voucher type programs.
Continued opposition to letting teachers determine
how best to teach their students. And this
cultural imposition of salute the flag, say
the Pledge of Allegiance. This is cultural
nonsense masquerading as policy. No to the
government will never again ask American
citizens to disclose their race as race,
ethnicity or skin color on government forms.
They want you to think that those questions can
only be racist or can only be for wokeness. But
the reality is that collecting that information
in so many different ways allows us to see
whether there are groups being discriminated
against, not necessarily openly, but in practice
and implicitly. And it's really important that we
have that data. We're not looking to use it in the
way Republicans claim it should be used. But if
you don't collect that data, you quite literally
have no idea whether there are real inequalities
along the lines of race, ethnicity and skin color
that we might want to address. We can't even
have that conversation if you don't collect
the data. OK? Number three, The soft on crime days
of cradle at coddling criminal behavior will end.
We will refund the police. Remember, the police
hasn't been defunded. And as a national or state
policy, these decisions are basically made at the
municipality level. There are some municipalities
who have made changes to bring in social workers,
or we might not replace all the police cars right
now or whatever. The police have not been defunded
in any systemic way, and it's simply another one
of these cultural issues. OK. Number four.
And these are kind of all over the map for
we will secure our border finish building the wall
and name it after President Donald Trump. The wall
is obviously not getting built. The wall is also
not the solution to our immigration problem. It's
a distraction. And naming it after Trump, another
one of these virtue signaling nonsense claims we
will grow America's economy, starve Washington's
economy and stop socialism. So this is an argument
number one against nonexistent socialism, another
cultural battle that they are fighting and
code for. We will cut social welfare programs.
Number six, we will eliminate all federal programs
that can be done locally and enact term limits
for federal bureaucrats in Congress. Term limits
I'm actually open to, but again eliminating all
federal programs that can be done locally. A lot
of programs can be done locally, but it doesn't
make any sense to me. And that's another way to
simply cut welfare. Number seven, we will protect
the integrity of American democracy and stop
left wing efforts to rig elections straight up
projection. Trump tried stealing the election,
and they are now just projecting that onto the
left. Total nonsense culture war issue number
eight We will protect, defend and promote
the American family at all costs, saying the
nuclear family is crucial to civilization that
can have within it any number of homophobic.
Transphobic and other disgusting aspects.
Number nine, men are men, women are women and
unborn babies are babies, so both transphobic and
anti-abortion. Number 10 Americans will be free to
welcome God into all aspects of our lives, very
clearly trying to take down separation of church
and state. Bring prayer back to school, et cetera,
et cetera. And number 11, we are Americans,
not globalists, which is sort of an allusion to
this America first nationalism type rhetoric.
Not a surprise that that's also something
they want to push. This is a plan,
guys. It's an 11 point plan. Nine and a half
of the 11 points are just a rehashing of the
same culture war issues that we've seen them
play for a long time. The other one and a half
are just excuses to cut welfare.
That's the plan, guys. That's the plan